joining us now is CBS News Chief
political analyst John Dickerson John
good morning to you I appreciate it
Senator Tom Tillis of North Carolina
yesterday who used a technical term for
World of farming involving bulls and
what comes out the back of them to
describe this whole situation uh and it
wasn't the only one well it wasn't the
only one it seems like it's getting
piled higher and deeper so what does it
say about where we are well what Senator
specifically was saying is the idea that
January 6 was not a violent Riot was
yeah baloney yes okay let's step back I
think we have to look at the court
filings first to understand where we are
with this relitigation of what happened
on January 6th with the court filing
show is that the incentives at Fox on
the business side and the personality
side were to give the audience what it
wanted not what was actually happening
and what the people who worked at Fox
knew was happening on something very
incendiary whether the 2020 election was
stolen Stakes couldn't have been higher
they knew better and yet they told the
audience what they wanted to hear
gasoline was on the floor and they said
well let's encourage people to discuss
having matches okay that's the the
mindset that that these court filings
show now take that to January 6. Kevin
McCarthy has decided that that mindset
that audience is still out there for a
relitigation of January 6th which was
itself supposed to be a lesson and what
was the lesson if you play footsie with
these dangerous ideas when the stakes
are really high it can be extremely
dangerous people can turn violent so
let's see who can die people can die
their lives yeah so let's not do that
that's what the lesson everybody thought
they learned and what Kevin McCarthy has
done is gone back into the closet and
said no let's have this conversation
again that's in part because those
incentives are still out there and
Tucker Carlson's incentives are to speak
to his audience and they still want to
hear that story which is different than
the facts but that's the story they want
to hear does the audience not care that
the people who are giving you the quote
facts don't even believe what they're
telling you and know it not to be true
well that seems isn't it a news
organization the important thing in the
filing is that the people who are
telling the audience what the audience
wants to hear private layers saying that
they know what they're saying or what
they're allowing on their air to be said
is not true that's the crucial thing
about this filing you know there's a lot
of mistrust in the way information has
been conveyed to the American people
over the history of American Media and
fox moved into that moment of distrust
in its original conception when there
were people who were journalists they
are trying to inform people that's
changed we've now seen in these filings
that the incentives are not to give
people a fair understanding of the world
but that you give people what they want
and if you stray from that as we saw in
the court filings about the news side of
it if you stray and tell them something
it's a little scratchy and at odds with
what they want to hear the news
Executives were saying no you got to get
back to telling them what they want to
hear yeah look if you if you like and
appreciate and cheer for everything you
see on your news program you're doing
the news wrong right you're receiving it
wrong as as an audience member you've
got to look for that scratchy
information if you want to be a citizen
and if it's not if you're not telling
them the truth on the most vital
high-stakes thing which is whether the
election was stolen take that now to
every issue that people are hearing
about immigration about crime economy
out of everything else if it's sorted
through that that leads to a situation
where our politics is being informed by
something that's broken are there no
repercussions all right John Dickerson
thank you always good to have you at the
time it's always good to be back thank
you